ukraine's foreign minister was in
brussels today delivering a blunt
message to nato leaders he says ukraine
needs more military aid right now
because thousands of people face
imminent death in the expected russian
assault on eastern ukraine just hours
before that russia was suspended from
the united nations human rights council
crystal gemensing reported a warning her
story contains disturbing images
the walls that once made up people's
homes
now rubble in the streets of northern
ukraine the cleanup seems futile yet
residents in cherney have worked to
create order in the chaos
across ukraine there are fears the worst
is far from over the battle for donbass
will remind you
was second world war
with large operations
the dawn bass in the eastern region of
ukraine is where there have been bursts
of fighting since 2014. russia
recognizes breakaway areas in that
region as independent states
nato now says russia is regrouping for a
major offensive in that area resulting
in pleas from ukraine's foreign minister
either you help us now
and i'm speaking about days not weeks
or
your help will come too late the scale
of death and destruction in bucha a city
that was occupied by russian forces for
nearly three weeks is serving as a
reminder of what's at stake we know that
starting february 24th
with this further invasion by russia of
ukraine the world has become a more
dangerous place
and that is why we need to make sure
that our partners are well supported by
nato canada continues to supply ukraine
with lethal and non-lethal weapons as
well as financial aid a recorded vote
has been requested it also helped
develop a draft resolution to suspend
the russian federation from the united
nations human rights council
we reject the untruthful allegations
against us said the russian deputy u.n
ambassador ahead of the vote
24 nations voted in support of russia
including belarus iran and china
93 agreed that russian's actions equate
to gross and systematic violations of
human rights the rare decision this
assembly has taken today sends a strong
signal of accountability
the kremlin spokesperson dmitry peskov
says russia hopes to reach its goals in
ukraine in the coming days it's about
guaranteeing our future in his first
western interview with sky news peskov
admits russian forces have suffered
significant losses in ukraine calling
that a tragedy
crystal gomencing global news
london